all right i have to tell you about
something interesting ben
cue the music
[Music]
[Applause]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool
a billion dollars
all right
billy of the week this person is not a
billy but they're incredibly fascinating
to me so i have been getting
just targeted on youtube like crazy not
from ads but for like things you also
should watch because my first million
there's this guy named alex hermozy have
you seen this person
yes dude this guy's all over my tick
tock feed i see this buff [__]
in every tick tock every other swipe is
this guy so who is this guy what's his
story i will tell you he looks like an
80s cop
had a baby with arnold schwarzenegger
he's like mustache
great mustache and just huge jacked like
he looks like a good looking dude
and very fascinating look he like right
when you see him he stands out ben's
pulling up a picture of him yeah i mean
he's yoked
and
i've been getting these youtube videos
from him everywhere like learn from me a
guy who has a business that's doing
nearly 100 million dollars a year in
revenue and i'm like what this guy looks
like he's 30 years old and i think he's
31. so let me tell you about this guy
and let me preface this by saying i
think this guy's legit but it's so it's
almost too good to be true and so i'm
like i wonder what the truth is right so
and all right so his name's alex so
basically he started out um when he was
like 22 23 he opened up a gym he scaled
that gym to three gyms still wasn't that
good of a business met some folks at
click funnels click funnels is a little
bit multi-level marketing
incredibly uh it's an incredibly just
internet marketing i wouldn't say
multi-level
um it probably attract but it's it's
it's it's it's the cousin of it uh you
know they all go to the same family
thanksgiving together yeah they're all
they're all they all go to the same uh
mormon church up in utah i would
guarantee you that
they let's just say they all know how to
run a call center
and
so anyway he like learns about that guy
learns about copywriting and then he
meets one of the guys at the company and
he says
wait a minute you're opening gyms that's
a horrible idea don't open gyms he was
like your gym's good he goes yeah
they're really successful
but
like the best gym isn't that successful
and they said to him dude teach people
how to open up a gym so he creates this
thing called gym launch and gym launch
is basically like a course that costs
around 20k i saw somewhere that it was
16k then i heard somewhere else it was
20k so let's just say 16 to 20 thousand
dollars and it's like a course but they
like hold your hand and you meet with
them like a mastermind it's a course
that teaches gym owners how to improve
their gym
and well on top of that according to the
website it's
financial freedom
okay sorry it's financial it's financial
freedom
and he's running these great ads and
he's got really good copywriting and
he's getting these people to um
he he's getting his people to uh
uh
improve their gym whatever hold on can
you go up to that founders section on
the website what does that say we slept
on the floor what does that say i want
to read this that's what he says this
story is he was like i was living in the
gym
because i didn't have any money gotcha
okay gotcha so yeah i was a former gym
owner who slept on the floor of his gym
when it when it was full i couldn't
acquire serve and retain enough
customers over the next three years i
became a spun or he became a sponge he
experimented blah blah blah became great
now he has gym launch okay go ahead
okay and then from gym launch he
launched another company called
prestigelab so once he gets the gym
owners coming to him he says hey like
buy these supplements too like you
should sell supplements at your at your
gym we did all the work and we know
which ones sell best and we're making
them you can just go ahead and buy it
from us
then he starts this third company that
says all right
yeah
two smart moves yeah then he starts a
third company says okay you've got a gym
one of the things that i told you was
that you need more leads i'm going to
create a lead company which i don't
entirely understand what that means but
it's kind of like a marketing company
and somehow they send they maybe they
set up your yelp and set up your google
adsense
they just they what they do is you
search uh you know gym santa like gym
near me san jose and then they're gonna
they know that the gym owner is not
buying that top click on google and
they're gonna buy that they're gonna
create a search engine they're gonna let
you say put in your zip code we'll find
a gym near you what's your email and
then they'll pass the gym owner your
email or your phone number and say
you know pay us per person who's
interested in a gym near you
and so
collectively
these businesses these three things that
i said are doing in the world of
according to his videos and my research
70 to 80 million dollars a year in fact
he just sold uh one of the businesses
the gym launch and supplement business
combined he sold 66 percent of it for 46
million dollars and in one of his talks
he says over the last five years both
through the sale of the company as well
as dividends i've paid myself 72 million
dollars
and
i thought that is nuts that is crazy
that is crazy volume yeah and this like
kind of blew my mind but there's another
business so his wife has a business
right or him and his wife they have
another business like acquisitions i
don't know man this is one of those guys
that's just like prolific he's got a
book on amazon he's done all this he's
like steve bartlett whoever you're
talking about he just like has his hands
in so much [__] i don't know how they
have something called acquisition.com i
was looking at this the other day
because i saw a video on tic tac and i
was like what's up with this is this
real i was literally like it's so funny
you did the research on this because i
had jotted this down as like dig in find
out and so what acquisition.com is
basically like uh it says do you want to
scale your business um you know i will
three x the business uh uh three extra
profits of a
of 100
businesses that are doing what between
one and 10 million ebitda per year
that are service-based businesses um
over the next five years if you want
help scaling your company without giving
up a majority interest click the purple
button below
and uh and then yeah it basically
says the same kind of story that you
were saying before and it's like how do
you want to you want to learn from us
here's my course here's my book here's
my podcast here's my here's my uh like
you know my link to join my accelerator
or whatever but this
i don't know if he's selling a course on
acquisition.com or if he's just trying
to get leads on small businesses he
could buy because he bought one business
and that's a photography business and i
listed the name of it it's called like
uh something fair um
i'll find it but oh here it is scroll
down to the bottom and chat you see
fairies yeah enchanted fairs f a i uh
and fairies sorry enchanted fairies
uh that's like a photography business he
bought
is that crazy though i mean so this is
like a pretty wild uh enterprise
yeah and he um he actually has some
pretty good stuff like i sent i because
i sent to my team like
i sent like i don't know 20 tick tocks
out a day but to three people it's like
this is the per okay so like i have my
friend who i'm like i can send offensive
funny things and actually you're in this
bucket too or you're one of the few
people that like i can send something
that's
like cancel-worthy if you think this is
funny i can send it to you and i can
send it to my brother-in-law that's what
i do i send it to both of those people
like i'll tell you what
this is bad but it was like
there's this twitter account i follow
that's like a like a meme accounting
like 200 000 followers and he tweeted
out he goes
men's mental health is not important
you follow up tweet he goes he goes
just get more
that was his tweet and i'm like i know
it's like a fart joke it's like i
shouldn't think this is funny
but it cracked me up because it's so
anti my silicon valley timeline which is
just like so super progressive
everything matters everything is justice
for everybody like
it's nice to just hear like where i'm
from in houston like i went to like a
pretty like ghetto school growing up and
like the sense of humor that's like from
that it just like hits home for me
potty jokes yeah just like you know it's
just like
it's like you don't bring
you don't bring your pronouns to the
hood type of thing and so there's this
like good humor that i just find really
funny anyway so
so you and this guy that's like my
inappropriate jokes and there's like you
know i'll send my wife or my sister just
like kind of like ah that's funny kid
stuff mom stuff whatever and then
there's like
little business or marketing hack
tactics that like i think are actually
pretty interesting so this guy alex
to me uh one of the reasons i suspected
he's legit is because his advice is
actually pretty legit yeah um and he's
not just saying general like
motivational quotes so for example you
say something like uh he's like little
sales thing that helps and these are
tick tocks right there's like 10 seconds
you don't have to like invest much in it
it's like he's like little sales trick
that kind of helps me getting somebody
to say yes is hard it's like a
commitment so if i'm like so would you
like to to sign up it's like uh let me
think about it let me get back to you
that's like on like what you'll get
frequently he's like i'll ask a no
commitment so i'll say
you know um if we're able to work out
the details would you be opposed to
actually signing up with us and they're
like no i'm not opposed to that
like no i'm not against it and actually
this is something that when i heard it i
was like oh actually i've kind of like
accidentally done this a couple times
and you know that's a good point there's
something there in the psychology cool
noted and like i'll pick up these little
things from him and like five other
people that are like you know in this
copywriting sales persuasion world then
i just think those are interesting to me
so i actually think this guy's uh legit
for that reason even though like
people look down on like lead gen they
look down on course businesses like
there's a stigma around course
businesses which is like oh you probably
couldn't do it that's why you're selling
courses let me change
let me clarify how i feel
i think he's legit and he seems like a
decent guy and he for sure seems like a
smart guy i don't know i don't know him
well but he seemed like a really nice
guy but he's in a shady industry not a
shady industry he's in an industry with
a lot of shady people not that he's
shady but supplements and like selling
this type of stuff his courses yeah yeah
not of course he i don't know if he's
shitty i'm just saying there are shady
people and also it's a twenty thousand
dollar course
and i frankly don't think i've got the
hutzpah to sell that to someone on the
phone yeah uh like it's that's really
bold and frankly i find it to be
challenging so i wouldn't say that i
think he's shady i'm just saying that
like that world has a lot of players who
are
yeah yeah yeah i'm with you yeah i don't
think you said anything naked i think we
were actually quite complimentary
towards him but um okay i like that
[Music]
you